hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lynn Doris a be rapid challenge we are
continuing with the first semi-final
match and this is Game three and a
Kimura lost the first two games so now
he needs to win two games in a row to
get back into the match and the force
Armageddon so Magnus with the white
pieces opens with E 4 and Nakamura for
this special occasion where he really
needs to get back into the match goes
for g6 the so-called modern defense also
is known as the robust defense so Carson
grabbed the center which is very
principled if your opponent develops on
the flank you wanna grab as many central
squares as possible we have D sits by
Nakamura in the ninth to f3
we have Bishop to g7 and now comes
Bishop to eat you we have E six and now
of course in just castles and now
Nakamura already had this position on
the board I think few times Knights the
e7 is the move you usually play here but
here he plays h6 and it is already as a
move 5 that we have a completely new
game so what do you do here
c4 magnus grabs more space in the center
and now comes g5 so already saying that
maybe g4 will also be an idea in the
future just further pushing those points
on the King side we have nice to see 3
Magnus just continues developing and
Knight the e7 now saying that probably
black book will be castling kingside
and Magnus goes h4 saying what is your
what's the idea behind those advanced
pawns here so Nakamura of course pushes
g4 and we have Knight back the e1
for the moment a passive Square but the
knife can be rerouted very simply into
the game and now h5 strengthening that
g4 pawn and Bishop to g5 by Magnus now
that you know you no longer have the h6
pawn the bishop will be very very strong
at g5 however nakamura immediately
dislodges it with f6 now is this one of
those positions where it's actually ok
to play f6 we'll we'll just have to wait
and see so now you have to retreat
Bishop back to e3 and now Nakamura just
castles and Magnus now has to decide how
to deal with this it's a very unusual
position
Pyrrhus like position but with the pawns
a very advanced age 4 in g4 and f3 seems
to be seems to be very strong for white
here for example you're capturing then
you open up or all of the files and
diagonals for white or you go f5 and
let's say after captures captures you
again get the g5 square and it's it's
just gonna be a very very strong
position for white you can also just
continue pushing your H pawn which will
be good for white so instead of f3
Magnus goes for d5 he strikes in the
center and now Nakamura replies by going
f5 and ok now that the point again moved
from f6 Magnus retreats with the Bishop
to g5 we've - up to g5 and now Queen -
eh unpinning so the knight can now
finally get into the game and now the
very interesting c5 not allowing a
Nakamura a moment arrest to start
developing his Queen side pieces
point is if you want to capture on c5
then you get this very annoying Knight
the b5 the thread is knife Capra's on c7
for King the Queen and the rook and
after let's say Knight a sex then d6
comes and well it's just not only very
very unpleasant but it's a very hard to
calculate what what's what's happening
here but why should definitely have the
upper hand
so instead after c5 Nakamura goes for F
Capra's on e4 we have C captures on d6
by Magnus captures and e6 captures on e6
Bishop captures on e6 and now Knight
captures on e4 so grabbing that pawn
putting pressure on the d6 pawn and
Knight to f5 nakamura offers up the d6
pawn if Magnus is interested in
capturing here twice however Magnus just
goes continues developing we have
Knights to d3 he's not interested in the
pawn it's an isolated beep one and he's
a very confident and confident that he
will be able to pick it up later on in
the game and also development you know
before before material so nice to see
six or as we usually like to say
activity above all so nice the c6
nakamura also continues developing and
now Knight to f4 putting pressure on the
bishop here also it's just very
important having these two nights here
controlling all of
squares so night c2d for just grabbing
more space in the center and now putting
pressure on the bishop here and Bishop
d3 not allowing the capture and just
putting it to a to a more optimal square
controlling this diagonal we have Bishop
to e5 by Nakamura and we have reached
the position from the thumbnail Magnus
goes rook to e1 aligns the rook and with
the Queen on the e-file and the Queen to
f7 by Nakamura but now feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
move for white here while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the the best tactic here and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's a knight captures an b6
knife captors and e6 because after
everything opens up its well it's just a
winning a pawn and all of the trades are
really favored black because even if you
get this position with pretty much all
the pieces accepted the Queen's and
rooks off the board then blacks King is
just very naked here and it will be very
hard to defend so now the point is of
course the Queen is under attack you're
also putting pressure on the night here
so Bishop captures on d6 and now comes
Bishop captures on f5 opening up and
attack towards the night here so Knight
captures here also defending the bishop
on d6 however now there's a double
attack on the bishop on e6 so Knight
captures an e6 putting pressure on the
rook here rook F to e 8 by Nakamura and
now that as the knight is attacked twice
Queen b3 adding another defender to the
knight Nakamura goes g3 wants to open up
open up the cross and sir King we have F
captures and g3 Carlsen not worried
about it because the knight here as long
as as long as the knight issue you don't
have Bishop to c5 check and then well it
could be very unpleasant and here
nakamura took several minutes to decide
how to go about the position as it's not
not at all clear how how to continue
white it definitely has a lot of
pressure here he goes for Knight
captures on g3 it either works or it
doesn't
it's not not very pleasant for white
either also with regards DF once course
you don't have looked f1 in the future
but Magnus finds a very nice idea rook
to e3 the idea is you want to add
another defender here with rook e1
double up here so tonight is defended
and then this rook can come to f3 put
pressure on the Queen and slowly but
surely make progress here because if the
Queen was not on f7 then you would have
all sorts of nasty discoveries available
due to this relationship between the
Queen and King so Nakamoto continues
development rook 8 the c8 brings the
rook into the game and Magnus does the
same rook 81 now the night is very
nicely defended and rook to f3 is now
again a possibility we have looked the
c6 by Nakamura now with ideas of if
maybe look the b6 can come you're also
adding another attacker here maybe you
can shift it the bishop somehow maybe
maybe you will be able to give up the
exchange for maybe rook captures and e6
to free the c5 square for the bishop so
there could be a lot of possibilities
here
however Magnus doesn't allow Nakamura
again a moment's rest so look to f3 puts
pressure on the Queen and now you have
to move the Queen and after Nakamura
moved the Queen he played Queen to g6
but now nothing is preventing all sorts
of nasty discoveries so once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the nastiest discovery while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
pretty much any discovery here is nasty
like Knight to f4 is the possibility you
go for the Queen although you have to be
careful if you go for the Queen then you
might run into some rook captures an e1
and with an eye being defended here
could be very very unpleasant so instead
of going for this Knight to a4 magnet
goes for the for the cleaner solution
Knight the c7 check for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show and it was
also in this position unmoved 30 that
Hikaru Nakamura resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
there is now checked at a black King
there is a double attack on the rook
here so whatever you play is completely
losing so for example if King to h7 you
first go rook f7 check so after you
force the King to the back rank now you
capture here with the check and there is
nothing more to be done
you can give up some pieces but let's
say Queen here just let's say a
discovery here the Queen you cannot
capture with the Queen because it's
checks we have to capture with something
like King captures and then Queen
captures and g8 will just be checkmate
and of course every other line also wins
sure very nice very nicely played by
Magnus winning all three games against
Nakamura in their first semi-final match
so like I said this does not mean that
Magnus to go straight into the finals of
the wind or asabi Keifer and they now go
into the second match and now he car
will have his chance to beat Magnus in
the second match to force a third match
and only then will we have the first
finalist of this Linda rossabi rapid
challenge so Nakamura has his work cut
out for him I will see what happens in
the next match sure now that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and my short
coverage of this very nice match I would
like to thank Geoffrey netting get a
Decker Ishmael Saeed Stephen green and
Henry's parents for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Lindo
rossabi checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day